parle tout de suite avec vous pierre
gentille et vous êtes avocat et
président du cercle pouchkine merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
ce bras de fer entre la pologne la
hongrie d'un côté et bruxelles de
l'autre quel regard vous portez
justement sur ce couac au niveau
européen je pense que déjà c'est d'un
vieux conflit c'est une vieille fracture
alors évidemment il ya un élément
d'actualité puisque ici c'est le plan de
relance plein voleurs de 750 milliards
au niveau européen qui de toute façon
sera adopté ya pas trop de suspense et
dessus je pense que toute façon on bat
les dards un compromis puisque
souvenez-vous la règle dans l'union
européenne c'est l'unanimité
donc on peut même pas faire sans la
hongrie
donc ici on a la hongrie et la pologne
qui font du front commun
c'est pas un hasard encore une fois il
ya une convergence je lirai en termes de
politique politique intérieure en termes
de valeur et puis contre contre la
commission européenne et même plus fut
généralement aussi contre les instances
européennes le parlement européen à une
politique qui n'est clairement pas celle
non plus de viktor orban et du
gouvernement polonais donc à mon avis on
va se diriger
de toute façon vers un compromis je
pense que on va en parler peut-être
après mais il ya une hypocrisie avec 7,7
cette notion d'état de droit de respect
de l'état de droit européen qui me qui
conditionne l'octroi de décèdent du plan
de relance
le premier ministre hongrois qui va donc
qui est donc l'autre aujourd'hui de son
homologue
c'est normal polonais le compromis est
justement quel type de compromis est ce
qu'on doit s'attendre aujourd'hui alors
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait le compromis
aujourd'hui forcément je dirais que le
compromis se situe pas vraiment entre
c'est peut-être même compris votre
question mais entre la hongrie et la
pologne mais plutôt entre les instances
européennes et d'une part et de l'autre
l'a enlevée et la pologne parce
qu'encore une fois je pense qu'il ya
quand même derrière tout ça le spectre
de ce qui s'est passé souvenez-vous il
ya quelques années en angleterre c'est à
dire que même si l'union européenne même
si la commission européenne combat
farouchement les valeurs des
gouvernements hongrois et polonais elle
ne veut pas et elle n'acceptera jamais
que ces pays sorte de l'union européenne
qu'il faut à tout prix éviter
kita quitte à passer sur effectivement
ces histoires de respect des valeurs et
de l'état de droit européen il faut à
tout prix maintenir pour la commission
européenne et plus généralement pour les
libéraux du parlement européen
il faut à tout prix maintenir la pologne
et l'enlever quand je pense que là on a
des gesticulations de madame c'est la
bonne der leyen les finalement vous
allez voir que d'ici quelques quelques
semaines peut-être que jour le sait plus
du tout où les délais le le projet
le club relance va être adopté pas trop
de suspense oui le compromis entre est
ce que justement varsovie et budapest
vont tenter d'aligner aujourd'hui lors
leur position mais est ce qu'ils sont
prêts eux justement un compromis pour
mettre fin à ce bras de fer ou pas ce
qu'ils peuvent d'ailleurs sur sept ce
plan de relance en repères oui très un
compromis et mais encore une fois à quel
prix et je pense qu'ils ont la position
de force parce qu'il ya certaines choses
qu'ils n'accepteront pas est typiquement
là on entre dans le coeur du sujet le
coeur du sujet ici c'est la condition
qu'ils aient qui est inclus dans ce dans
ce plan de relance conditions plutôt
sanction qui interviendraient en cas de
non respect de l'état de droit européen
alors nous occidentaux ici en l'espèce
français effectivement le respect de
l'état de droit nous on est un vieux
pays un vieux pays du droit on a inventé
quasiment tous notre droit le respect de
l'état de droit on pense que c'est le
respect de la démocratie c'est le
respect des décisions des juges mais en
réalité la vision de l'état droit de
l'union européenne
ce n'est pas que cela ce n'est pas une
vision juridique ça c'est hypocrite
c'est une vision fondamentalement
idéologique et politique la vision de
l'état de droit européen c'est le
respect des droits mais le respect des
droits individuels
on ne parle pas ici du respect de la
souveraineté populaire
on donne pas ici du respect du scrutin
comme j'ai pu entendre mais en réalité
ce qui est visé c'est le respect des
droits individuels dont on comprend ce à
quoi ici on pense aux positions de la
pologne sur l'avortement
on pense à tout un
un nombre de 1 certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été prises par viktor orban pour
limiter l'immigration est donc quelque
part le droit individuel des migrants à
se déplacer librement dans l'union
européenne c'est aussi un des dogmes de
la commission européenne donc on a
fondamentalement ici en fait un conflit
un conflit de valeurs entre deux visions
qui s'affrontent
d'une part la vision libérale libertaire
de la commission européenne plus
généralement des instances européennes
et de l'autre côté la vision nationale
la vision populaire populiste comme on
voudra la plaie des pays du type hongrie
pologne même plus généralement de
l'europe de l'est qui souvenons nous
n'ont pas rejoint l'union européenne
après la chute de l'union soviétique
pour simplement adhérer un grand marché
libéral et ont encore encore moins à
adhérer aux valeurs de l'union
européenne il voulait simplement avoir
un parapluie pour se protéger au cas où
l'union soviétique revenez demain c'est
ça c'était d'avoir la possibilité
d'adhérer à une communauté démocratique
or ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce qu'il
voit c'est que cette communauté
européenne n'est pas réellement
démocratique
merci beaucoup à vos pairs gentille et
pour cette analyse et pour avoir rendu
en direct à nos questions sur rt francs
rappelle que vous êtes avocat et
président du cercle pouchkine